während einige teile in brasilien
wirklich fast aufgegeben haben weil die
situation der so katastrophal ist muss
man sagen dass die welt hier am strand
von rio wirklich immer noch dieselbe ist
also man könnte versagen im vergleich zu
deutschland steppte der bär
die leute trinken alkohol hier wird
sabrina verkauft sie hatten keinen
abstand tragen keine masken feiern
liegen sich in den armen verbringen
einfach ein ganz normalen strand tag wie
wir ihn zuletzt gewohnt war noch 2009
ungefähr
und ich habe auch mit einigen gesprochen
und viele tun das er heißt ein kleines
fieber ab oder als ein kleiner schnupfen
die ganze corona pandemie und nehmen das
alles nicht ganz so ernst dass bleibst
du woher kommt das also ein großer teil
davon trägt auf jeden fall president
personal dazu bei das haben wir ihm auch
bei dem ersten stimmen geber gehört also
wohl szenario ist der der hier diese
ganze corona pandemie kleinredet und das
schon seit monaten
er macht das alles eigentlich deshalb
weil er möchte dass die wirtschaft am
laufen gehalten wird sagt aber dass die
leute keine masken tragen sollen hat
sich die selbst schon demonstrativ
einmal vom gesicht weggezogen tut das
alles als einen kleinen schnupfen ab der
schon wieder weg geht obwohl er selbst
corona hatte und sagt einfach die leute
wollen wieder ran an die arbeit und mir
ist auch aufgefallen als er mit einigen
leuten hier gesprochen haben dass viele
ihre hand in pistolenform geformt haben
das war so das markenzeichen seines
wahlkampfs also man sieht hier schon
dass viele solidarität hier mit boyzone
a row zeigen mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren